мене звуть Адам Красновкі, я
представляю медіа-центр України.
Я вітаю всіх журналістів, які приєдналися до
нас, щоб поширити правду
про війну в Україні.
Ця війна фактично увійшла в
усі сфери нашого життя
і вплинула на всі сфери нашого  life
сьогодні ми будемо говорити про
освіту, тому наш сьогоднішній гість - сергіс
Гарліт, міністр освіти і
науки України, моє перше запитання до
вас: нещодавно міністерство
прийняло рішення щодо нових змінених
правил прийому до університетів та
коледжів, які можуть  ви говорите про це, будь ласка,
дуже дякую, що взяли,
оскільки ми говоримо про
розвиток нашої країни про війну,
ми маємо говорити про освіту
цього
року буде зміна
вступ до університетів коледжі
незалежні
також будуть трохи змінені
діти  не складатимуть чотири тести,
вони складатимуть один тест, і це буде
національний багатопредметний тест,
там будуть три різні сесії
, щоб  кожен має шанс скласти
всього буде 28
сесій екзамен
складатиметься з трьох предметів українська
мова
математика та історія україни
я сподіваюся що правила будуть остаточно
розроблені та опубліковані офіційні ресурси до
кінця сьогоднішнього дня у
нас було декілька зустрічей з
Комітетом університетів і
професійно-технічних шкіл ми досягли
консенсусу щодо процесу вступу,
і ми спробуємо завершити правила
прийому до кінця сьогоднішнього дня,
крім того,
ми також матимемо
можливість запропонувати пробні онлайн-тести нашим
студентам перед тим, як вони складатимуть  справжнє випробування
, щоб усі учнівські лідери
могли скористатися шансом і підготуватися далі,
не могли б ви дати нам
огляд шкіл, як вони функціонують, я
розумію, що діти ходять до школи
дистанційно, але коли вони підуть до
школи особисто,
давайте поговоримо про попередні часи
хробак so kovit навчив нас багато чому, як
організувати навчальний процес, щоб забезпечити дотримання
основних обставин
і як організувати  Я
успішно обробляю онлайн на
сьогодні понад дванадцять тисяч
шкіл відкрито та працює у нас є тринадцять
тисяч сімсот шкіл загалом
приблизно 450 шкіл знаходяться на тимчасово
окупованих територіях близько однієї тисячі
шкіл
було повністю знищено
ну пропонуйте три типи та три форми
навчання
онлайн  офлайн та змішана львівська область
пропонує офлайн навчання очне
навчання
вісім областей україни пропонують лише
онлайн навчання або гм діти
на канікулах у нас тисяча
дітей 1 800 дітей
тимчасово переселені
тимчасово переміщені, але вони мають
шанс приєднатися до будь-якого  школа та продовжувати
навчання онлайн, я пишаюся тим, що
будь-яка дитина, яка переїхала з донецька
луганська, де б вони не були, вони можуть
приєднатися до навчального процесу, вони можуть приєднатися до
будь-якої школи онлайн, і це дуже допомагає
на сьогодні, тому діти мають доступ
до освіти
У нас сьогодні працює 1500 дитсадків,
це також дуже важливо  Це
великий внесок у систему дошкільної освіти,
тому що
вихователі працюють, отримують зарплату,
заклади працюють, вони сплачують
податки, і це допомагає економіці, а
як щодо дітей, які опинилися за
кордоном, які змушені були втекти з країни та
тих, хто перебуває на тимчасово окупованих
територіях?  як вони можуть продовжувати свій
навчальний процес з
початку війни наше міністерство разом з нашими
партнерами за кордоном і всередині країни
ми вжили ряд
заходів, щоб кожна дитина, де б
вона не була, навіть на тимчасово окупованих
територіях, мала доступ до
навчального процесу
наш заклад  міжнародна українська
школа, яка має 36 філій
у Європі,
вони пропонують навчання,
щоб діти могли приєднатися до цієї школи онлайн,
тому діти, де б вони не були,
навіть на тимчасово окупованих територіях,
вони можуть мати доступ
до освіти, і вони можуть зрештою отримати
атестат про середню освіту,
крім того, у нас є багато  um партнери
атмосфера школа оптим  школа
lico school тощо.
Це приватні школи,
але вони запропонували безкоштовний ресурс.
Безкоштовна платформа. Освітня
платформа. Ця платформа дозволяє дітям
отримати доступ до шкільної програми,
наприклад, атмосфера. Школа прийняла 35
000 дітей у всьому світі, і ці
діти мають доступ до освітньої
програми.  онлайн якщо
говорити про тести ті діти, які
опинилися за кордоном як вони збираються
складати випускні тести підсумкові шкільні тести та
вступні тести чи
можуть вони зробити вони повинні відкласти це чи
вони повинні здавати це наступного року
дуже дякую за це запитання
ми були  враховуючи таку
можливість, ми також провели
зустрічі в середу та четвер
з комітетом науки, гм, освітніх
інновацій, ми спілкувалися з нашими партнерами в
країнах ЄС,
тож давайте розділимо це питання на дві
частини,
тож, по-перше, цей остаточний тест
, щоб отримати сертифікат  середньої
освіти, а другий – це
вступні випробування до університетів і
коледжів  en
фінальний тест
вони можуть пройти онлайн,
тож ми фактично вже протестували його, ми
спробували й протестували під час копіювання,
говорячи про вступні тести,
наприклад, деякі діти com
деякі випускники шкіл в ЄС,
я мав нагоду поговорити  моїм колегам
з країн ЄС з Міністерства
освіти
ми
разом
будуємо мережу
центрів, де діти можуть проходити такий
тест вступний тест до університетів і
коледжів за кордоном,
щоб це можна було зробити в університетах або
в незалежних центрах тестування,
це дуже важливо для нас  тому що ми
хочемо, щоб наша молодь поверталася
і розбудовувала україну
інше питання Україна була дуже
популярною і привабливою країною для
іноземних студентів багато студентів з
інших країн приїжджали здобувати
освіту в україну ви абсолютно
праві 80 000 студентів
були
студентами  українські університети, і
вони були іноземцями,
це було
те, чим ми пишалися,
і це означає, що є довіра до
система нашої сьогоднішньої освіти ми
також
розглядаємо дистанційне вступне тестування для
таких студентів, тому що ми хочемо, щоб наша
освіта була затребувана в усьому світі
незалежно від безпекової ситуації
в світі україна буде жити
залишитися з україною слава україні слава героям
дякую за
приєднався до нас, дякую, що прийняли мене, тож
нагадаю, що
нашим гостем був міністр
освіти і науки україни саріш халід